whoa I just noticed something
my gun is played by a real person why
don't you fuckers tell me next thing you
know you're gonna tell me the kid isn't
CGI Lucas thinks to me your appearance
of Java will make us jizz our pants but
Lucas is wrong as hell is there
seriously nothing that tells Anakin that
some part of his pod is broken right now
okay I'll admit it pod racing is badass
and I'll even give two sins off for it
but it's not gonna help this piece of
trash is ultimate sin score that much
just in case you were wondering what
happened to this guy you didn't care
about here's a scene explaining what
happened to him
alien rat carcasses here get your alien
rat carcasses here okay so how did
Anakin catch up to Sebulba after his pod
didn't start for the first 20 seconds of
the race and if his pot is faster than
why has any bloom past him already he's
had two major delays and somehow he's
right behind a leader remember when
Sebulba sabotage Daniken's pod before
the race even started yeah after three
laps and going zany miles per hour only
now does that affect the ship so these
computer screens tell you when
something's wrong after all but only
after a ton of damage has been done
oh isn't that cute this movie thinks
it's been her and Jabba does an
impression of me watching a NASCAR race
oh all the essential parts we need I'm
going back if you hear groaning it's
because these camel aardvark things are
CGI abominations that were called into
existence by an unmerciful god we're
leaving was not a coincidence yeah it
was look at the things that had to
happen before they ran into Anakin he
had to stumble on Jar Jar on another
planet
take him in have him show them where his
home was get released by the Gungans
survived going through the Naboo core
have shipped problems on the way to
another planet just happened to land on
Tatooine befriend the child slave of a
guy who sold the part they needed and
then have Jar Jar accidently get into a
fight with a professional pod racer so
Anakin could break it up even then the
kid just kind of joined him without an
invite and I still don't think II clean
those racks so what the hell is this
probe been doing the whole time Darth
Maul sent three of these things out late
one night about 25 minutes ago with
movie time these things couldn't find
the broken-down ship for one whole
evening during the pod racing the next
day and a five-hour goodbye to Andy's
mom qui gonn and anakin are already
running long before they know a suit is
just about ready to attack i think i'd
drop
why couldn't you feel Darth Maul
approaching a lot sooner than this thank
God George Lucas shot this lightsaber
battle dance super close-up jump cut a
vision because I almost figured out what
was happening in this scene take off why
does an obi-wan help qui-gon fight the
sky
neither the Jedi are important for the
ship they just need to get Queen Amidala
to the Senate and later the Jedi Council
tells him to go investigate Darth Maul
anyway so why not now
Anakin Skywalker meet obi-wan Kenobi
meeting that should have been a lot
cooler than it is we're a democracy the
people are decided tuck him away skip
Padme will go from maternal figure in
this film to sexual partner in the next
like that and that is creepy as space is
cold
it sure is but aren't you on a ship
doesn't it have heat I made this for you
I carved it out of which poor snippet
when did you have time to do that the
total time qui-gon and everybody was
down on the planet was like three days I
most of that time was spent fixing up
your podracer also jou portion of it I
don't need this term then were you by
because we already have a creepy
romantic connection that won't be spoken
of aloud until you're old enough for me
to see your jaw portion of it if you
know what I mean wink many things will
change when I reach the capital any it's
called puberty curse on the entire
planet is one big city thanks narrator
I'm grateful for your concern Chancellor
do you think that maybe this fake queen
has actually been playing the Queen for
so long she's gone to deep undercover
you think maybe she feels like she's
actually the Queen right now these
airships all stay in their lanes despite
there not being any clear back to the
future two lane markers or anything
Queen Amidala you look so obviously
different from the last time I saw you
how do those handmade and disguises even
work the courts take even longer to
decide things than the Senate they do
Welsh took an hour and 24 minutes for
Yoda to even show up in this movie you
want to figure out where things went
wrong it's having Jedi play politics and
only using their powers to smash up king
robots why didn't this movie started a
secret Jedi training ground something
kind of like Dagobah where Darth Maul
comes in an assassin he's a Jedi Master
played by Delroy Lindo or someone else
90s and start the movie with that
instead of tax law a boy his cells of
the highest concentration of
midi-chlorians I have seen on a life
form therefore he's a good guy I think
it is possible he was conceived by the
midi-chlorians the midi-chlorians were
later arrested for sex events you refer
to the prophecy of the one who will
bring balance to the force
no because Star Wars would never do
anything as stupid as having some
ancient prophecy muddy the waters right
who makes these prophecies it started
right here with the taxation trade
routes Star Wars Episode one it's just
as exciting as watching c-span I present
Queen Amidala
recently elected ruler of the Naboo who
speaks on our behalf
making my job as senator completely
superfluous also space politics
also this dangling dildo bullhorn hairdo
I know you want me to say something
about the et delegation down here but
I'm much more concerned about the
oogie-boogie delegation appear
absolutely butchering the running man
the boy will not pass the council's test
master jealous much
do not defy the council master not again
who be hints at a much better movie that
we'll never get to see afraid to lose
her I think mmm well wouldn't you be to
Jedi Council makes it out like loving
your mom is bad assholes
here is the path to the dark side movie
continues assault on fear as though it
never once led to a saved life or an
avoided accident also if you're telling
me no Jedi has ever had fears you Yoda
you're a liar and a dickhead everyone
has fears why don't you just teach the
kid how to move beyond them instead of
acting like it's a total cheese for even
having them samuel l.jackson just
grateful to be in these movies will now
stroked his chin knowingly user thinking
use the people gonna die ladies and
gentlemen the power convertors line of
the new trilogy no it will not be true
you'll do just one on a rant about how
feared leads to the dark side but isn't
the council practicing fear by not
allowing the training of Anakin an
apprentice you have qui-gon impossible
to take on a second
the code forbids it why I heard Yoda
talking about midi-chlorians
lorian's I've been wondering what are
many chlorines skip I don't understand I
think Jake Lloyd got a bum rap look at
the cast of this movie it's full of
amazing actors Ewan McGregor Samuel
Jackson Natalie Portman Liam Neeson
Keira Knightley and they're all playing
blocks of wood and almost here Lucas on
set that was a good take but try doing a
line more like you're dead inside you
know like you're a computer Lucas
deserves any and all sins that might
otherwise have been directed at the
actors in this movie there's no chance
you can roll up the high edge of this
platform but we'll cut away before that
so no one will ever know did something
happen to the blockade remember
absolutely nothing changed since they
left except the Trade Federation has a
tighter stronghold on the planet so why
the free reign to fly into Naboo all the
sudden I am Queen Amidala hey I'm sorry
for my deception but it was necessary to
protect myself how were you also fooled
by the ancient statues that are never
explained and have no bearing on the
plot accidentally inspire lost we shall
make you bombad to general well he
certainly is qualified we can enter the
city using the secret passages on the
waterfall side secret passages ex
machina somehow George Lucas manages to
rip off the neverending story once we
get inside you find a safe place die and
stay now is he doing on this mission
anyway why isn't he chilling an Obi
Wan's apartment somewhere watching
cheesy how to be a Jedi videos Denham
Innes accidentally inspires all the
albums made by t-pain prequel screen
that guy should have objected that day
steggy
oh no one's listening to your dumbass
well why didn't they just do this before
also what kind of force field keeps out
cannon fire but let's draw it's just
walk through it we all handle this I
don't know why the Jedi have to take
Darth Maul by themselves they have a
whole army behind them that could easily
take them out right now well Darth Maul
is a criminally underused badass and
duel of the fates is one of the finest
pieces of film score ever written so
we'll take three sins off here without
looking back wait here it is
while looking for the trigger Anakin a
trained pilot first pushes to dashboard
buttons before grabbing the obvious
trigger device everything this scene is
and represents also in the span of six
seconds Jar Jar hits more targets than
all the stormtroopers in the entire Star
Wars franchise combined and on accident
why isn't Anakin dead he doesn't even
know how to fly this thing yet he's
running straight into the enemy without
any problem
I'll try spinning that's a good trick
yeah try that asshole kid we hate who we
already know is going to survive
whatever bullshit we see try that Birds
we're about to see our first true scene
of suspense in the movie but what the
hell is this place this is some Galaxy
Quest here oh yeah the Duncans are
fighting in this battle I completely
don't care about them I mean forgot
about them Jar Jar makes a fantastic
tactical decision by complete accident
after ha this one's a decoy look I know
you want to make these Trade Federation
guys half-wits but do they really think
the real Queen would just run out the
open like this to save a decoy also why
are they certainly unmade up Queen was
the Queen anyway I know Amidala came out
from hiding to the Gungans but to the
rest of the world too well it isn't a
Jedi sit doing without there being an
impossibly unending fall of some kind
nearby it's falling up from the inside
yeah funny story some little kid
accidentally autopilot at one of our
spacecraft inside the enemy ship and
then accidentally fired a torpedo to set
off the very chain reaction we need to
defeat this thing I know I didn't
believe it either but what are you gonna
do am i right now this is podracing no
it's not too bad you don't have the
thousand other ships that were forming
the blockade earlier oh well
enemies are controlled by one power
source and die when it explodes cliche
Darth Maul taunts obi-wan here but
wouldn't it be pretty easy for him to
kill obi-wan by like spear throwing his
lightsaber five feet down into obi-wan
space I mean where's he gonna go to
dodge that
Darth Maul stands perfectly still while
obi-wan does all this bull killing also
the coolest character this trilogy has
gets killed like a little bitch in the
first movie this exudes you're still
alive
goodbye quite on I'll be sure to mention
you in the next trilogy psych now thy
side
why did Amidala bother going back into
her queen makeup and how fit after doing
battle with her soldiers did they
actually sit around and wait for her to
get on formal before sending the Viceroy
back confer on you the level of Jedi
Knight the council does because you
killed that one synth guy and not
because you pass whatever nebulous
trials were talked about earlier but
which were never shown grave danger I
fear in his training fear leads to the
dark side Yoda agree with you the
council does the Jedi Council changes
their mind about training Anakin because
he lucked out destroying the droid ship
they still sense fear in right nothing
else has changed right Huygens funeral
is for some reason held on the boot what
will happen to me now you turn into
Hayden Christensen of course there's no
doubt the mysterious Warrior was a Sith
hmm
always true there are except when you go
on right then there's only one right
right but which was destroyed the master
or the apprentice this would be a great
way to end the movie but well the first
movie ended with a big celebration so I
guess this one has to as well
oh gooberfish
well not condone a course of action that
will lead us to war open war is upon you
what you would risk it or not there are
fields endless fields where human beings
are no longer born we are growing just
keep swimming just keep swimming just
keep swimming swimming yeah I need parts
for a j-type three to seven nubian
what's a nubian cycle break off a stray
from the herd and push him to the right
this is getting out of hand now there
are two of them double impact there's
two of them now there are two of them
this time there are two
terminator to help me obi-wan Kenobi
you're my only hope
I'm glad to have met you Anakin I was
glad to meet you too
Oh my life I think my technicals are
dropping
oh boy oh boy mom sure can on your any
pizza hello everybody and welcome this
year's annual Las Vegas international
dodgeball open brought to you
exclusively here on ESPN 8 the Ocho
there's only one person who guns an
engine like that it's gotta be the
roughest tough guy on machine gun Joe
turbo
we've been in the cockpit before Oh sir
I've never been up in a plane before
never seen a grown man naked you you
blown up damn you